I was writing with some concern about
what now gets labeled feminism on
campuses which has to do with I think
dialing back a lot of progress women in
particular I've made at establishing
ourselves as consenting adults
Laura Kipnis is a professor of
communications at Northwestern
University and author most recently of
men and ongoing investigation in which
she asked the perhaps subversive
question of what do men want Laura
Kipnis thank you for joining recent TV
hi we will talk about your book in a
second but let's first talk about your
perhaps unlikely new role as poster
child of the anti campus political
correctness movement earlier this year
you write an essay about sexual paranoia
in academia for chronicles of higher
education in which you criticize the
sort of administrative changes
regulatory even social changes at the
University of Northwestern
as regards sexual assault and just
sexism in general and then the reaction
goes bananas there are protests and
eventually even to students filed a
Title 9 complaint against the words that
you wrote saying that it was somehow
going to stifle the but chilling effect
on their lives here when this all
happened the reaction did you at least
have a time chance to pause and
high-five yourself remember your theory
proved correct or did it go straight to
the Kafkaesque nightmare well I should
go back a bit and say that I was writing
in this article as a feminist and I was
writing with some concern about what now
gets labeled feminism on campuses which
has to do with I think dialing back a
lot of progress women in particularly
I've made at establishing ourselves as
consenting adults so a lot of the
impetus of these new campus causes to
take consent away from women and
students and put it in the hands of
administrators so I was you know writing
against the this wave of new regulation
particularly the codes governing
professors and students dating so what
happened then was students staged this
protest carrying mattresses in pillow
and carrying a petition to the
president's office but the whole thing
is that the mattress had become a symbol
at Columbia's everyone knows having to
do a student on student sexual assault
and I had written nothing on that
subject so when I first saw this photo
of students carrying mattresses I was
kind of befuddled because it did seem
symbolically incoherent to me but I also
did think I'm not sure quite high five
myself but I did think this wasn't going
to end up looking good for the students
so I think that proved to be true did it
kind of suggest to you that maybe the
problem in the way that we talked about
it and our changing rules is worse than
you thought it did prove what I had said
I thought you know more than I could
have imagined because by carrying this
petition to the president's office
asking for me to be censured for having
written an article you know asking the
administration to protect them from you
know what I can only think is a kind of
very slight umbrage of some of you
having written something that they don't
agree with I mean yes it did prove one
of the points I was making which was
that this increase in these codes and
regulations is increasing students own
sense of vulnerability so that
everything becomes an injury and the
question I asked was how does this leave
them after graduation to cope with you
know what happens out in the world where
where there aren't administrators to
protect us from you know minor injuries
talk about a little bit about what you
described is the Inquisition that
happened afterwards a title 9
investigation that sounds like
gobbledygook for those of us we haven't
been in on college campus really for 25
years they haul you in you don't have
access to a lawyer but you can have a
support person is that like a support
animal or something
what happens there to talk us through
the due process of what happened to you
next well I had written a couple of
paragraphs in the first article about
this situation was going on on our
campus about a professor who had been
accused of sexual misconduct with two
students
and I made brief reference there were
two cases there was one of an
underground and one of a gadget graduate
student and I had made a very brief
reference to the graduate students case
like Mike brief I mean seven or eight
words so what I found out I got this
letter from the title nine office that
that complaints have been filed against
me I under you know title nine and I
like everyone else thought well doesn't
this have to do with like gender
discrimination or sexual harassment
I wasn't that familiar with it and I
didn't see how it could apply to an
article and I was being charged with
retaliation and I didn't see how I could
be charged with retaliation if I hadn't
committed some sexual misconduct against
somebody in the first place that I'd
been charged with so the whole thing was
very baffling and in many ways it is
still baffling it's one of the things I
want to do is learn more about title
nine so it this emanates from the
Department of Education and the Office
of Civil Rights and all campuses that
get federal any kind of federal funding
have to stay in compliance with title
nine regulations which are very vague or
they risk losing federal funding so of
course northwestern is in the position
if anybody files a complaint to jump
into gear and pursue this investigation
so that's kind of what happened and yes
I was allowed to have a faculty support
person not a lawyer and that was the
first time to even hear what the case
was against you at that moment and
that's the moment that you also had to
respond to it the procedures are you
know also baffling and I don't know if
they're like written down somewhere I
found them out as I went along
like I said can I have a learn no you
can't have a lawyer they wanted me to
show up to a meeting and they would tell
me the charges they wouldn't put the
charges in writing so they wanted me to
show up so they would tell me the
charges in person and then have me
respond to questions so I said no I'm
not going to do that
I want the charges in writing and then I
will think about them and then I will
show up to a meeting where I'll answer
questions so we went back and forth
about this I never got the charges in
writing we finally had a Skype session
where they told me the charges you know
verbally and I tried to type them
because I have
bad handwriting and I didn't trust my
ability so instead I have these wildly
miss type notes where it lists these
charges so I didn't answer questions in
that skype session but then I had a
meeting with them that lasted three
hours over to the University brought in
two outside investigators from a firm
another in another Midwestern city flew
them in to conduct this investigation
that went on for 72 days over
essentially seven words in this article
Wow yeah that's where I get the cough
desk and you know to be cliche that's
where the cough desk part of it you know
happened I mean it just seems like an
appalling waste of time and money for
something that should be free speech in
a place that we in theory believe our
bastions yes I was trying to estimate
how much this cost and in the end what
they came up with were 260 page
single-spaced reports and additionally
to abridge reports that were 5 pages
each single space so I you know I mean
like I thought it's got to be like 50 to
100 grand for this and I mean the
interviewed maybe eight or nine
different people for the process so I
was a lot of person hours let's talk a
little bit about kind of more the theme
of the articles a bit you are saying
that sort of modern feminism is the
feminism that's hijacked by melodrama
that there's a sort of an obsession with
helpless victims and and and these and
kind of like super powerful predators
why how did that happen what how do we
get to that point from a feminism that
those of us rolled or kind of remember
which was more about kind of agency and
empowerment what happened yeah yeah that
was the feminism that I came of age with
and I'm still formed by I mean they've
always been these contests among
different forms of feminism and there
was a version that got called radical
feminism early on although it's the what
I would say is the more conservative
version more right-wing version that was
associated with people like Andrea
Dworkin and Kath
McKinnon and it was you know they were
making a push against pornography and so
there was this legal case that got made
by McKinnon who's a law professor that
words constitute like harmful actions so
they were trying to define speech itself
as potentially not just kind of a path
to violence but as a form of violence
and and even though I'm not sure people
actually read MacKinnon and jorgen now I
mean I I still do and in the men book
one of the chapters is on Dorkin she's a
I think a fascinating figure but I do
think that that version or tendency in
feminism kind of got mushed together
with other sorts of tendencies say what
on campuses is called identity politics
you know this idea of you know
marginalization its kind of privilege of
marginal subjects and various forms of
oppression and and I'm not you know I
can't I'm somebody on the Left I mean I
there's a lot about minority um you know
issues in the history of America in the
history of you know American campuses
and all of that that I think has to be
addressed but some of the forms it's
taking and this culture of injury that
has developed I do not think are the
right ways of addressing particularly
when it comes to women's situation now
obviously your case and the case of
people who suffered more kind of injury
in in process on campus are interesting
and kind of outrageous on their own for
the unfeeling bastards who are nowhere
near academia and don't personally care
about you how does this trend on college
campuses
having to do with this kind of melding
of identity politics plus sort of speech
I mean there's a there's been a lot of
people making comments about not going
on college campuses to do comedy anymore
um the the sense that the students are
being infantilized
how does that affecting the rest of us
who are nowhere near a college campus
it's an interesting question I mean what
there's this term rape culture that gets
pushed around now and I mean I got
accused of fostering rape culture
and all of this stuff is leading to more
regulation I mean not just on campuses
but workplaces you know to UM other
kinds of anti consensual relations
things that happen in business is now
corporate culture you know it's also
regulated by these kinds of things and
to some degree it addresses what
absolutely were abuses of power in the
past particularly by men in positions to
power towards subordinates but you know
it does it's not just I you know don't
think of academia as existing in
isolation I mean it's a vast part of the
culture and you know people who go to
colleges go get out of college and you
know enter the real world and do things
and make laws for example or you know
other kinds of work workplace
regulations so I can't think that it
doesn't affect everyone or that academia
is some you know isolated situation you
talked about in your book about kind of
the modern a male as being sort of a you
know or at least rumored to be a kind of
anti libidinous they're more sad sacks
how would you describe the changes of
the modern male right now to say twenty
or thirty years ago what and and what
what caused those changes in your
estimation well I'm not the one who's
going to blame feminists for male
listlessness although I certainly know
that you know particularly online there
is a lot of that kind of blame going on
I mean I do think that there's like a
kind of vast redoubling of gender roles
uh and it's I think in process and I
think that you know that combined with
like certain kinds of economic insults
to men like the loss of the breadwinner
or loss of you know job security the
family wage all of that women entering
the workforce I mean I do think that
there's a period of uncertainty that has
all sorts of psychical cycle and
psychological effects on men and how can
that not affect relations you know
romantic sexual a little bit and all all
of that is it just too complicated to
assess or is it is an improvement I mean
I I grew up hanging out with a lot of
new left people who are all very you
know sexually advanced and all this kind
of stuff which just meant they got to
grab
more asses than the old Archie Bunker
crusts is the new listless male at least
better behaved than the you know
progressive males of the 70s I you know
if you read somebody like Hanna Rosen
wrote the book the end of men I mean you
know men have really been kicked in the
you-know-what a part of the anatomy you
want to specify by the economy so you
know I don't think that's good for
anyone and I mean I'm somebody who wrote
in a previous book of called a female
thing I mean that I think a lot of what
gets called improvement in women's wages
as commet the expensive men because
those are men measured as as percentages
so if women are now making like 72
percent of the male wage instead of 70
it's because male wages have declined so
you know I do think all of that stuff
has to be looked at let's talk about one
of your final chapters the women who
hate men where you talk about Andrea
Dworkin have you mentioned earlier but
also Larry Flynt and you kind of share
their sense of disgust at the sex act
can you talk about these unlikely pair
and what that means for for all of us as
we talk and think about the various
gender Wars and things the first essay
in the book is about Larry Flynt who I
have the pleasure of meeting a couple
attention I guess I met him once and
interviewed him on the phone a few other
times because what happened I had
written a long time ago an essay about
hustler called desire and disgust is
very interested in the class politics of
Hustler magazine and this in a way was
my taking aim at Dworkin and MacKinnon
and other anti-porn feminists who I
thought neglected other issues in
pornography like class so I started
reading hustler which was actually kind
of difficult as a kind of proper visual
you know women it really is disgusting
but he came very interested in the ways
that use disgust as a political tactic
so I wrote this essay which somehow
Larry Flynt ended up reading his
ghostwriter had given him a copy and so
I ended up meeting him and spending some
time with him and then I when his
autobiography came out he actually used
stuff from my essay and put it in the
first person as
he was I had thought of it you know so I
was both flattered you know I thought
okay I guess I got it right or is it
said in the when we wrote more about him
I mean I think he has this kind of sense
of roving identity is a bit of a
scavenger and he'll be whatever anybody
wants him to be including a First
Amendment hero but I open the book with
Larry and my kind of encounters with him
and feelings about him and in a way that
I think he sort of changed me reading
hustler II meeting him and thinking
about him made me have to be sort of
cognizant in my own the ways that
disgust kind of governs I think often
feminine or female Sensibility you know
so it was it was an interesting
experiment thought experiment but then
the last chapter was about Dworkin who
in they are you know hustler had taken
off after Dworkin in many occasions and
she sued them and it led to a very
important Supreme Court decision about
the expansion of critical speech so
Larry did have this you know I think
vast effect on American culture but so
there's a coda in the end where I talk
about this sort of meeting via the
courts or this lawsuit between these
unlikely figures who are both in their
different ways motivated by sexual
disgust that's a fascinating a match
that wouldn't necessarily occur to
everybody my final thought about about
your campus travails here the reaction
to it the reaction to your case which
you've written about again for
chronicled higher education does it give
you hope does it give you anti hope
where do you think we're going from here
in the great kind of campus speech Wars
one of the things that happened after
the title nine ESSEC him out the second
one is I started getting this flu of
email from people who'd also been
brought up on title nine charges or or
they imply that they were a lot of
people said well something like that
happened to me but I can't really talk
about it
did you have a gag order on your it says
we something like we expect you to keep
this confidential so Wednesday was a
gag order and as I invested I couldn't
find like was there some punishment if
you didn't so I just decided to go for
it and expose it and I did write the
piece before the process had been
finalized because they were delaying and
delaying and delaying the verdict on me
so in fact the verdict came out later in
the day that the piece went on line I'm
not sure that there was a connection so
I do think I will try to write more
about the process and try to get more
information from other people that have
been through it because it is there are
these secret tribunals going on that no
one knows about and people are afraid to
talk about and I think that a lot of the
people who've been brought up on charges
are more reluctant to talk about it
because I don't think they feel they're
on as for firm ground as I was I mean I
was brought up over an article if you're
brought up because you were dating one
of your students you know it's you're
less likely to want to come forward but
this is going on in secret and I do
think it's worth knowing about it I
think there should be more transparency
so I do wonder if people are going to
start to push back more against this or
go public partly because and I'm not
trying to make myself into like a you
know hero of the title 9 process but I
did feel like I was in firmer ground
going forward partly because I'm tenured
so I think maybe more people will start
to come forward well that's certainly
hope so lower tipnis thank you very much
for joining us and for recent TV I am
Matt Welch